[Music]
from the smallest single-celled organism
to the largest creatures on earth every
living thing is defined by its genes the
DNA contained in our genes acts like an
instruction manual for ourselves four
building blocks called bases are strung
together in precise sequences which tell
the cell how to behave and form the
basis for our every trait but with
recent advancements in gene editing
tools scientists can change and
organisms fundamental features and
record time they can engineer drought
resistant crops and create apples that
don't Brown they might even prevent the
spread of infectious outbreaks and
develop cures for genetic diseases
CRISPR is the fastest easiest and
cheapest of the gene editing tools
responsible for this new wave of science
but where did this medical marvel come
from how does it work and what can it do
surprisingly crisper is actually a
natural process that's long functioned
as a bacterial immune system originally
found defending single-cell bacteria and
archaea against invading viruses
naturally-occurring CRISPR uses two main
components the first are short snippets
of repetitive DNA sequences called
clustered regularly interspaced short
palindromic repeats or simply crispers
the second are casts or CRISPR
associated proteins which chop up DNA
like molecular scissors when a virus
invades a bacterium casts proteins cut
out a segment of the viral DNA to stitch
into the bacterium's CRISPR region
capturing a chemical snapshot of the
infection those viral codes are then
copied into short pieces of RNA this
molecule plays many roles in our cells
but in the case of crispr RNA binds to a
special protein called cast 9 the
resulting complexes act like Scouts
latching onto free-floating genetic
material and searching for a match to
the virus if the virus invades again the
Scout complex recognizes it immediately
and casts 9 swiftly destroys the viral
DNA lots of bacteria have this type of
defense mechanism but in 2012 scientists
figured out how to hijack CRISPR to
target not just viral DNA but any DNA in
almost any organism with the right tools
this viral immune system becomes a
precise gene editing tool which can
alter DNA and change specific genes
almost as easily as fixing a typo here's
how it works in the lab scientists
design a guide RNA to match the gene
they want to edit and attach it to cast
9 like the viral RNA in the CRISPR
immune system the guide RNA
directs cast nine to the target gene and
the proteins molecular scissors snip the
DNA this is the key to crispers power
just by injecting cast nine bound to a
short piece of custom guide RNA
scientists can edit practically any gene
in the genome once the DNA is cut the
cell will try to repair it typically
proteins called nucleuses trim the
broken ends and join them back together
but this type of repair process called
non-homologous end joining is prone to
mistakes and can lead to extra or
missing bases the resulting gene is
often unusable and turned off however if
scientists add a separate sequence of
template DNA to their CRISPR cocktail
cellular proteins can perform a
different DNA repair process called
homology directed repair this template
DNA is used as a blueprint to guide the
rebuilding process repairing a defective
gene or even inserting a completely new
one the ability to fix DNA errors means
that CRISPR could potentially create new
treatments for diseases linked to
specific genetic errors like cystic
fibrosis or sickle cell anemia and since
it's not limited to humans the
applications are almost endless CRISPR
could create plants that yield larger
fruit mosquitoes that can't transmit
malaria or even reprogram drug resistant
cancer cells it's also a powerful tool
for studying the genome allowing
scientists to watch what happens when
genes are turned off or changed within
an organism CRISPR isn't perfect yet it
doesn't always make just the intended
changes and since it's difficult to
predict the long term implications of a
CRISPR edit this technology raises big
ethical questions it's up to us to
decide the best course forward as crisp
relieves single celled organisms behind
and heads into labs farms
hospitals and organisms around the world
wrap your head around the implications
of CRISPR with this playlist on genetics
or check out some of the other
mind-blowing science being developed
around the world and in the universe
right now
[Music]